thank you so
this this talk will be more focused on
like work that i have done as opposed to
uh one last example since i've done and
it will be in its work that's joined
with uh
vasily kiska
so let's go back to
the so we've done a lot about how to
represent information structures and now
let's think about how we represent games
so sometimes we are designers and we get
to design games let's think about that
uh for a little bit
so this is the slide from before we have
some private information that's in the
hands of the agents and we get to choose
what actions are going to play in this
game how these factions match in 12
thumbs and i'm trying to think about
what
uh i can implement and what not
and let me do it in
notation that might be more familiar to
people that have worked already with
mechanism design which is usually we
think that already the set of states of
the world represents the information
that the players have
usually so so basically what this side
does is the identity
so given theta each player you know also
coordinates and usually these action
sets that we endow the players with with
all the messages
because at the end of the day what we
are interested in is in aggregating this
private information that they have
and because we want to use this
information to determine what what
what's the best thing we can do
so this is in in a sense if you want to
think about it through the lens
of something you know this is a little
bit like agent-based learning
the information uh the information is in
hands of agents and you want to
incentivize and so the information that
you're receiving might
uh you have to take into account the
incentives of the person that's giving
it to you and and you're trying to
overcome those incentives
yes
oh yeah so a 0 will be like our the
allocation so basically for instance if
i wanted to auction a gun
is who gets the good and how much they
pay me
so these are the the allocations that
the designer is in control of
but thank you that's uh so basically
what we are trying to understand is
what assignments of types to
distribution server outcomes we we can
implement thank you for
so oh and this is because i was changing
the size last night so for forget it
forget about that um
so basically the idea so these b1s and
bns are my
m1s through mns so basically the idea of
mechanism design is we take as given the
information structure we're trying to
design a game and as i said the first
order of concerns that information is in
the hands of selfish players and
before we wanted to talk about all
information structures now we want to
talk about all games i'm going to call
those games mechanisms
why because someone a long time ago
decided that these are going to be
called mechanisms and
i don't have a better excuse than that
now
how does um so what mechanism design
does at least in static settings it
gives us a language to talk about all
mechanisms via the revelation principle
so what is the revelation principle as a
result that
goes
very long
a long while back but basically what it
says is the following
you can always write the following game
you can tell the players your message
sets and this is why calling the
messages makes a lot of sense your
messages sets are your set of types
i'm going to ask you to tell me
your types
and let's say that i wanted to implement
pi
if you tell me that if i aggregate the
reports of all the players and i end up
with the vector theta prime
then
i'm basically going to implement what i
said was going to do when the state is
stayed upright it doesn't this doesn't
mean that this true state is data prime
it just means you told me that the
steady state of prime i'm going to trust
you i'm going to say implement five
so basically
if i can i can find a game that has bias
and equilibrium outcome
if and only
i can implement pi as an equilibrium
outcome of this game where i ask the
agents to give me their information and
i follow blindly what they tell me
moreover if there is a game that
implements pi
i can
without generality
do it in a way where the agents will
tell me the truth not because they are
not strategic but because i will make it
there worth their while to tell me the
truth
so i know that this sounds a little bit
strange but this is just function
composition
so basically what i'm saying is
the players know their types
they can tell me messages
and as a function of their messages i
will choose some
a and that's the a notes that id was
asking about
so the
players are going to report something as
a function of their types
and
my game
will take the messages and choose some a
possibly at random
and i'm saying that i know that this
game implements pi
so that means that when i compose
the reporting strategy
with
what i told them that i would do when
they tell me their messages
this is exactly the pie so this is the
assumption i'm assuming that there is a
game
that implements that implements pi which
means that when i compose
what they tell me the messages
with what i told them that i was going
to do as a function of the messages i
get by
but that means and i'm pretty sure that
many of you know because i already hear
way more than i you know
that
i can just ask me asking them to tell me
the the truth
and then do whatever what i was doing
before
and this and
and this triangle was long known for a
very long time in economics but the
thing is that we didn't have game theory
to formalize this
so this idea this is called the
mount writer triangle
and it's a very very old idea
but for a long time people didn't have
the language of game theory to formalize
it because the important the import the
property that we care the most about
is that if this was the agent's
best response to this game
then telling the truth is the best
response
so this is this is the incentive
property that we want to preserve so
usually when
this result this revolution principle
type results have some equilibrium
notion embedded in them
and
when you move from the this call
so-called indirect mechanism to this
mechanism where you have to respect the
types you're preserving the solution
concept
does this make sense
has to be the best response
let me yes that the identity has to be a
best response
there's a
big literature
um
by
one of the authors in that paper that
spoke to haman masking eric maskin uh
pushed a lot this idea of full
implementation so not only that the
identity so
that every equilibrium of the game
also implements pi so so if it was also
an equilibrium remember what we were
talking about before that i might tell
you to take an action but you're
indifferent between the two actions
if that if it's also in a clear part of
an equilibrium for you to take the other
action for instance may not tell the
truth
you all equilibria of this game has to
implement pi
but
for today we're going to do what's
called partial implementation so i need
that
truth telling is a best response
any other questions
okay so
what this results says is that in a
sense this idea that we have strategic
agents with information and that we're
trying to learn it the regulation
principle sort of makes up problem news
because basically we're so we're going
to abstract from the decentralized
learning process that ends up
with the designer having information to
implement the allocation
but so basically we're saying that
without loss we can focus on mechanisms
where the people are the only
information they repeated
but not because they are done but
because it's in their interest so if it
was if what i was trying to implement
didn't give them the correct incentives
to tell the truth then i cannot take
them like that
so in general you might have heard that
there's distortions of the location or
the rents that the agents receive in
order to tell the truth
now
having the revelation principle doesn't
mean that all mechanisms are truthful
so for instance if you play the first
prize auction please don't beat your
values because
you might go home
unhappy
um and it's not necessarily that
trustful mechanisms are better so
there's research showing that
people even if you're facing with a
trustable mechanism they don't
understand that it's a truthful
mechanism and all health breaks knows
but
the obsession with truth telling and the
revelation principle because this will
be a talk about being obsessed with the
revelation principle is that it gives us
a recipe
i don't want to be thinking about this
world where i'm going over message
spaces and equilibrium i want to think
about this world where i'm have a fixed
message space and where i have a set of
constraints that ensure truth setting so
the revelation principle allows me to
think about
a problem that's essentially an
equilibrium problem
into a constrained optimization problem
i have a well-defined set of mechanisms
and con and i'm maximizing over this set
subject to constraints
so this is this is why we are
like economists in general are obsessed
with this not because we think that they
said mechanisms exist in the wild but in
order to know what i can do in the while
i need to be able to write down the
program
and mechanism design i think has been
very successful in the while i took this
from anna carlin's slides from the boot
camp in 2016
and i'm pretty sure that we can up
there's even more applications and one
of the reasons is that this result makes
it very easy to work with
now let's go into something that looks
more like the environments that we look
at in the workshop where things are
dynamic so now imagine that i'm not
choosing an allocation only for today
but we're doing this repeatedly so every
day we hold an auction or probably every
other second or so we hold another
auction
so we're thinking about repeated
interactions and you we might be
thinking that either the agent's private
information is persistent
or it evolves all the time if i'm
uh i'm seeing for instance different
requests for ad slots for different
consumers that's like my valuation
evolving over time
now this is a
very burdening area both in econ cs and
or and the newest in parenthesis because
actually people have been doing dynamic
mechanism this science since the 80s so
there was not like myers and optimal
trends from 1981
uh baron de santo which is one of the
first dynamic mechanisms in the same
paper since 1984. so people were given
in theory and they just went to races um
and basically the idea knows that the
designer needs to learn information
that's not you as in any sequential
decision process the information that
the designer learns today might be
relevant not only for today but also for
tomorrow
uh so you might know that if you awarded
the good to someone today
then they have a budget constraint so
tomorrow they might not be willing to be
as high you might want to get the go to
another player tomorrow
the problem now becomes that the players
start being concerned about
what the designer learns today because
what the designer learns today they can
use it tomorrow so think about when
you're online shopping
sometimes you're like should i take the
most expensive relaxing amazon well
maybe a muslim tomorrow shows you the
most expensive product for the next
category and last time i was here at
simon's we had this game in the we were
sharing apartments with a couple other
economies we will
open up our uber apps and it turns out
that when i was doing inlay i had sort
of told uber that when i was on a
seminar trip i was willing to
pay high prices maybe because someone
else was paying for the trip but then
over quoted me high prices or like
higher prices than the other people were
in the same house
so you could imagine that
for looking agents then um
they understand this
so if you know that google is going to
adjust your reserve price today
tomorrow by using your bits today you
might want to
do something with your bits today and
this is an economics this is called the
ratchet effects because it can sort of
unravel
you can end up in a situation where you
don't want to reveal anything about you
just because you're so worried about how
this information is going to be used in
the future
now
if in a dynamic setting we knew that the
designer was committed to the mechanism
and by that i mean that designer
set the rules
and
now he learned that i really value the
good high but he cannot take it back he
already promised me that tomorrow i will
get the good for one dollar and now he
knows that i bought it at 10 and they
are like
i i that's i told her one dollar so
she's getting the good for one dollar
then we will have again a version of the
revelation principle
where the agents are going to
uh
be reporting truthfully their new
information each time to the designer
and we're going to be able to focus on
truthful there's a start here because
equilibria we have to start thinking
about dynamic game solution concepts but
stiller will be truthful earlier in the
game and again we can focus
well loss in truthful equilibrium
and of course what changes is how we pay
the agent's friends we might be thinking
about how we have to compensate them
today for how we are going to use their
information tomorrow
and what happens is that sometimes these
rents are high enough that the optimal
mechanism what it says is that the
inform even if i learned today the
information that i needed actually i'm
not going to change the mechanism so
there's a huge literature in economics
thinking about the determinants of price
discrimination for instance you have a
durable good that you're trying to sell
and you have buyers those values are
evolving over time
and the
threat the fact that if you want to
lower the price at some point to
serve uh answer of demand
the the incentives that it triggers on
players with higher valuations that
basically means that in many settings it
is optimal to not drop the price so a
very classic result is that uh it's a
and this is a paper from the 70s is that
if you want to sell the rebel goal and
you have commitment
you need a lot of evolution in a sense
you need the values to change a lot to
be willing to to lower price
um
if you have commitment
so let's go a little bit uh but but the
thing is that that i think introduces a
problem that relates to his question
about do we trust the designer or not
so let's think of a seller he wants to
sell one unit a favorable good he has
two periods over which to sell it
and the buyer's value is going to be
persistent so if i value the good 10
today i will value it at 10 tomorrow
and
the optimal mechanisms i was inspiring
is basically to set
the same price in each period and the
price i'm going to set is the one that
uh solves a monopoly problem in the
first period so that's that's the
the the solution to the problem
so what happens is that the designer
is supposed to ask the buyer
um do you want to buy the good at price
p
the buyer checks and she realizes her
value is less than p
then she says no
we're going to the second period the
designer is supposed to
ask again for a price of fee and if the
designer has commitment
he already knows the answer
he because
because the buyer said no before the
buyer will say no no but actually now
the seller you might think the seller
now wants to think about this again
because he says okay i know that theta
is less than p
and actually i know that everyone that
has theta less than p told me now in the
first period i have a new demand
function
and now that means that the designer
might be like ah
i will offer a new price
uh
that will be lower than p because my i
know that everyone that's in the second
period has none lower than b
and now what what happens the mechan the
incentive properties of the mechanism uh
go a screw
because
now let's think of the agent in period
one that has a value higher than b
and now that anticipates at the moment
that she says no the price is going to
lower so now you will have some agents
in period one
that will say no
so if you're worried that the designer
will use information that they have
learned to adjust the mechanism
then what you will lose are all the
incentive properties of the mechanism
does this make sense
because basically the talk will be to to
think about how do we
think about mechanism design and how we
think about representing mechanisms when
we're worried that the designer will
react so they
will take the information that they
learn and they will do the best with it
moving forward
so
yes
no so no that that that that's great
because that means that it was confusing
me i shouldn't i shouldn't have
separated this in two slides
so under commitment
the seller
should
set p and not move it
but what i was trying to illustrate is
that
now that you know
that everyone without below
the
p doesn't buy in the first period
actually you're not happy with the
mechanism anymore because you have a
residual demand
and under that residual demand there's a
new price that's optimal so the
commitment solution
in the in this case requires that you
ignore whatever information you learned
and actually if you think about it from
the point of view of the revolution
principle
the designer in the first period learns
data and now they know exactly how much
value they build and they could come
back to you in the second period with a
new offer
and they don't
um
so so basically um
the
the commitment assumptions is very
important in this particular setting and
actually there's many
there's many mechanisms
that
uh
that have this feature so it's not
something about selling durable goods if
you have dynamic ad auctions
or you have repeated sales
or you have procurement
mechanisms in these cases are all have
this feature that with forward-looking
agents
you need to pay them so much
if you want to use information in the
future that you end up ignoring the
information that you learned to
compensate so so you distort the
location a lot to compensate for the
rents
that you need to give
so
what what
so basically what we would like is a
theory of mechanism design that does not
realize so strongly on this assumption
that the designer will ignore the
information that he learns in order
and not optimizing
now the first issue is that
there's only one way to have commitment
which is i
announce a mechanism and i stick to it
no matter what there's many ways in
which i could have limited commitments
and let me i think here this is one
setting where an operation is about um
so so basically there's there's many
different ways and haven't been explored
in the literature and economics i think
that the ones that we're most familiar
with are
short-term mechanisms which is like the
setting that i showed you if today i
tell you the goodies sold at p
and you accept p i cannot say oh
actually do you want i regret it i would
like to raise the price
so if i announced something to them
committed for today but i'm not
committed to what i'm going to do for
tomorrow onwards
so this is a setting that's in economics
it's very
common because it models like sequences
of government for instance
um
but i know and also all the papers that
i cited before from uh cs and or are
also in this environment i think the
other setting that is more popular is
when you cannot you commit even to
today's mechanism so
sheng woo presented his work with
muhammad when i was here in 2019 but
there's other papers in this realm where
it's basically we run the mechanism i
see the outcome of the mechanism i'm
like
i don't like it i go back and i say guys
let's do this other mechanism
and uh so in a sense these are like uh
very opposites what i'm going to focus
today is on the first one
so basically what we're going to have is
an uninformed designer that is going to
interact with one agent that's
persistently and privately informed we
can allow for the for the type to evolve
over time but it's easier to to state
the result
without this and the designer can commit
to this mechanism and he cannot commit
to what the agent will do in the future
sorry what he will do in the future with
the agent
and there's many examples that follow in
this category
and despite this being something that
you would think that people are sort of
obsessed with because it seems like a
first order consideration
it's an incredibly hard problem there's
like very few papers both in cs and or
and in econ that analyze optimum
mechanisms in this setting
and this takes us to the second issue
which is that even when you narrow down
what you mean by limited commitment
the reason we don't have a lot of
results is that we don't have a
revelation principle
and you can think about why the
revelation principle might not hold
at least the truth-telling part is
if you tell the designer your
information now you know that the
designer will
go and use it you might not have the
correct incentives to tell the truth
so basically what
the result that i'm going to show you is
how do we restore the revelation
principle in this setting and you will
see that it has a lot of connections
with the first stop so
um
it's um and it will look more like
patient persuasion
like
so i don't think that
my impression is that i could
parametrize
you know i i think that at that level of
abstraction there's no difference
but but the thing is that the difference
is that
i set a set of rules
in period zero
and they are supposed to be
inaudible
and now the question is
we saw the outcome of period zero
and i asked myself do i like what i said
that i would say in videos one two three
with commitment even if you
were like shoot i should now i should
lower the price
you are not going to change it that's
that's so the thing that you said you're
going to improve here you're going to
stick to it
with limited commitment you could say
you know what
i'll uh i'll reoptimize my plan
does that make sense
yes
if i can re-optimize in particular i can
keep the same strategy
so so the thing is so
i think that i guess this is um a
different difference between a strategy
and a behavioral strategy so at the end
of the day we're going to play
equilibrium and
my strategy i will stick to it because
it will be an equilibrium the question
is where do i
question myself
so so in commitment my plan has to be
optimal in period zero
and i never check again whether it's
optimal
in
with limited commitment you're going to
check that the plan that's going to be
fixed
is optimally 0 in period 1 302 and so on
and so forth for every for every
contingency
so when you said that with commitment
the optimal strategy doesn't change the
price
what that's saying is that even if the
seller says all right here is my pricing
algorithm
the fact that they would have to publish
this pricing algorithm means that they
can't actually achieve better than just
keeping the price
exactly
yes so of course with commitment you're
always better off
[Music]
and i want for for this talk because
it's uh it requires introducing more
things that are
not yes it will complicate
more than
uh clarify but
we can get the same result
uh as in a similar version of the result
with with evolving types
no so so there could be persistency
so i think
so elon has a very beautiful paper on
repeated sales
uh with iid types
and then
there's
so there's two ways in which commitment
can buy to this setting or or lack of
commitment can buy to setting one is
that
if what you learned today is useful for
tomorrow now you might want to use it
but the other way your commitment
bites which is i think before i read
elon's paper i haven't reflected on this
is the following
in a dynamic setting
with commitment if the agent said i want
to sell you a go
the first moment you tell me no
i don't want the the goal
or i don't want to participate in your
mechanism i can be like we are not
talking anymore
and i might be very tempted to go on and
retry sending you the good but i will be
like
i i i i don't want to listen
but with limited commitment if i know
that there's an opportunity for trade it
will keep coming back to you so even if
your values are iid
which will mean that for instance all
these issues about the revelation
principle will be mute because
i
what i learned today
has no implications for tomorrow i
there's another part where commitment
will bite which is or lack of commitment
will bite which is that now your
participation constraint looks different
because you know that maybe you say no
to today's mechanism and tomorrow i will
come back to you and be like okay let's
play this hour game whereas with
commitments i won't have that i will say
the first time you say no to me
that's that's it which gives the
designer a lot of power
nicole
don't you have like four different types
of results
the other extreme with commitment with
full commitment and iad types i can i
have to leave you some runs for today
but i can extract without something like
expose a sequential ir i could extract
all your rents moving forward because
in period t you and i are as informed
about what will happen from t plus one
onwards so i can charge you excellent
for your rents
uh
so i think that that's sort of like the
the setting that
uh elan and renat were comparing
themselves against that with commitment
you have a lot of power in that setting
and the
ability to
this inability to keep coming back to
the agent sort of induces something that
looks like a sequential ir but i i i
don't know about the fault here but it
would be
questions
all right so
in order to basically tackle this
question i need to be a little bit more
abstract about what i mean by a
mechanism so when we went over the
regulation principle i gave you like the
standard results but
uh there's a lot to unpack so the way
we're going to
so so the way to think about a mechanism
even in the meyers in setting is the
following the mechanism has two set of
messages a set of input messages these
are what the agent reports
and a set of output messages ads signals
and this is what the principal will see
so basically the way the mechanism works
is the agent sends a message
and i hope someone finds my use of
agents hilarious um
and then the mechanic the the he
privately sends a message the mechanism
takes a message randomizes over the
signals and the allocation and the
principle what he says are the signals
on the allocation so this is what the
public outcome
so if you think about the revelation
principle that i told you before
basically what it says
is that in a setting where
the agent has no actions to take not
like the first lecture today so in a
setting where the agent only has private
information
communication between the principal and
the agent will be direct
between the agent and the mechanism will
be direct so the agent will report the
type
it is without loss of think that the
mechanism can make the communication
observable
so that each s maps only to one m so the
principal when he sees the s he knows cm
and the reason is that with commitment
the principal can ignore the information
he learns
and then
it is without laws to focus in the case
where communication is truthful so when
the principal sees the s not only his
learner's agents type report he learns
the agent's true type
now
of course this is the source of the
issues we're trying to take this result
to the case of commitment because we
already discussed at length why what
happens why the agent would like to lie
if the principal will react to the
information
so there's a very nice paper
from
from the 2000s by western straus
and what they do is they keep the
assumption
that communication is observable so that
when the principal sees the output
message he learns the input message and
what they show is that
if you wanted to characterize the
principles best mechanism
then without loss you can ask the agent
to report the type but something has to
give and it will be truth-telling
which means that you lose the beautiful
characterization of like now when you're
thinking about optimal mechanisms you
have to carry around the agent strategy
because each mechanism has a different
truth-setting constraint for the agent
it's not clear what lie you want to tell
so
this is um
and this is very related to an
observation in so
this is the paper on complexity of
dynamic mechanism design the last
section
they're thinking about repeated sales
without commitments and they have this
example where you might need like many
rounds of communication
when there's limited commitment so this
lack of
when communication is direct it's not
truthful it's very related to this idea
that you might need to communicate many
rounds between the principal and the
agent in one period to find an ic
location
now
moving on in time
they have the same authors they re leave
this restriction so they are like let's
look at a larger class of mechanisms but
they look at a one-period setting
and then they show that we can make
communication direct
it's on the principle on the agent
and make equilibrium communication
truthful
so you can think that basically so the
paper that
i'm sort of
describing with acidity basically what
we are going to do is characterize what
the set of output messages is
if you like that's the the most
simplistic
uh view so basically and and this should
be very familiar from what we talked
about this morning what we're going to
show is that if you want to
label your signal some way
they're going to be the beliefs that the
principal holds about the agent's type
so
so basically
we have the written always ask the agent
to report the type and the principal
will learn whatever he needs to learn
about the agent moving forward
and the beliefs that the mechanism
outputs like the literal information
structures that we saw this morning
are exactly the beliefs the principal
have when he does base rule using the
mechanism under the assumption that the
agent is telling the truth
so basically what this says is that with
limited commitment you can always think
of mechanisms that take
the agent's type
and
maps it into distribution or posteriors
and allocations
but the result has one more
simplification in this class of
mechanisms that i think it's easier to
to do on the board so let me
be very informal and say so the
mechanism what it says is for each
agent type
there's a probability of getting a
certain allocation and a certain belief
and i can always
do a lot of total probability and write
this
like first i will draw
a belief given the agent type and then i
will draw an allocation
given the belief
and the agents type
so what the result says is that in
equilibrium the principal will use
mechanisms where the allocation is drawn
independently of the agent's type
condition on the
so what the mechanism is effectively
doing is designing a blackwell
experiment
and then conditional on the belief is
designing the location
so when the principal sees the
allocation he hasn't learned any more
than what he learned by seeing the
belief about the agent's type
so basically
in abstract terms what this is saying is
that if the principal wants to give each
type of the agent a different allocation
well he has to learn the agent's type
there's no way of like if the allocation
separates the agents the mechanism
separates the agent's types
and otherwise
if you want to pull types together the
all of sites have to get the same
allocation
and because of this feature of like the
blackwell experiment and
and the location rule
we call these direct blackball
mechanisms
so it's kind of good that tomorrow there
will be all the talks with uh
uh about david blackwell's work because
today we have seen
uh twice an application of this idea of
uh how to write experiments
okay
so
just to give
a simple as a simple insight of what's
going on
when we started talking about static
mechanism design what we were trying to
replicate is how each type maps into an
allocation
that we will have that pie and we were
trying to match that distribution
but here because we also have to
keep the principal
happy with the mechanism he chose we
also need to be
replicating
how each type
maps to the different beliefs that the
principal has
and so the first thing
we did is the first thing is like what i
showed you at the beginning of the
second lecture with mechanism design and
the second thing is what we're doing in
the morning with information design this
belief approach
so instead of this what the result is
saying is that instead of designing the
mechanism for a given information
structure what the mechanism is doing is
designing both
what we use to call the mechanism the
mapping from types of allocations but
also information structure so you're
designing both
how google
is running the auctions and how
the information that it just learned
about the billers is used to update the
prices
and if you think about
with what you we did this this morning
what's happening here is that
from a perspective so we said that the
principle in period t has commitment
to whatever he's doing to your team
and he is concerned about two things he
has to elicit information from the agent
but also he cannot control what's
happening from period one from period to
plus one onwards
so the principal in brt wants to keep
the price
p today and tomorrow and the day after
tomorrow but this guy over here might
not be comfortable with keeping the
price
constant if new information is learned
but what the principal and purity can do
is sort of control information
that depends on pure t plus one does
so in a sense the principle impurity
is designing the information structure
for this guy because this guy uses
the information structure to
the information he learns to
do the mechanisms in t plus one
and so on and so forth
and also to elicit the information from
uh from the agent so that so this is why
we get
uh this is why we have a problem very
similar to this morning
now the question is
this morning we saw
you can write information structure in
terms of beliefs or
actions
here actions are very complicated
because actions are mechanisms and they
are mechanisms for tomorrow the day
after tomorrow the day after tomorrow
and the principle from the day after
tomorrow is playing a game with the
agent so you might think that there's
multiple equilibria so you're not only
saying
what mechanism you should choose you
should say what game what equilibrium
should play so that it could be very
complicated
so in a sense it's sort of magic
that you can collapse
that just by by collapsing everything to
the belief you can get
you can get this to work but this is a
setting where
using actions action recommendations
would be very difficult and that's why
we use philips
yes
the
agents are not learning anything right
they don't have any music
no no
but the principle is learning about the
agent
so now you might imagine that you want
to
you want to slow down the learning
yes
so basically if you if you wanted to to
think about um
what
what mechanisms to restrict the
principle to these are these are the the
mechanisms and like before
uh you will have truth selling from the
agent
so that means that now we can remove
again the agent from the equation
instead of thinking about what the agent
will do when i show him a new mechanism
so
yeah so basically that's that's the the
one thing that i wanted to highlight
which is that
now again we're going to have these two
constraints on the mechanism and which
which is that the agent has to be
willing to truthfully report and that
the mechanism has to match the
principles equilibrium believes but once
you have these two things basically the
agent
becomes like
constraints that the mechanism has to
face the problem is that you still have
the game between the principle and
essence his future self this this
reaction but that one is uh that one is
i don't think it's possible to get rid
of
right so
okay so mike my question
it's uh so if i remember if i said kids
create this paper correctly what she
does is something like she does a
reduction to like using
the utility space right
uh the outcome space
so basically what she says yeah my
question is there's a generalization of
that
um
so the thing is that so vasiliki in her
paper what she's using is a mechanism
for communication is observable between
the principle and the agent
so
in a sense
by looking at the space of allocations
then you don't need to worry about
like how changing the mechanism changing
changes the agent's best response but we
have um
so in the setting of her of her job
market paper we show that
with these mechanisms now the principal
can potentially do more so they are not
the same
um
so can the mechanism
not allow itself to learn anything from
the first period
or is there some restriction no so the
print so the principle always sees the
allocation
and and so if because otherwise you're
right like if i don't see whether i sold
the gold
i don't want to
i can restore commitment
so the principal sees the allocations is
there any reason to see more information
than
so
in the papers that we have worked on no
but we are always in these settings
where like sort of this idea of the
ratchet effect kicks in that the agent
is worried that the principal learns
things and then extracts friends but you
could imagine that maybe
the information that the principal
learns today is useful for both the
there's an efficiency motive
but economists like this sort of like
adversary like uh principal versus the
agent settings
so i don't have an example but you might
imagine that you want to encode more
information
i thought i saw another hand
so i was going to show you an example of
like how you would derive this but i
won't because i have like 10 minutes and
it will be
too much we have a bunch of applications
because
the framework is very general so we
don't have restrictions on the
cardinality of the set of types or the
payoff functions
so we have a bunch of applications where
we have
uh
looked at
our optimal mechanisms in infinite
pricing settings to sell an optimal loan
or we have a paper where we study how
you will design your product line if
you're
concerned that once you learn that the
buyer likes high quality goods and then
tomorrow you're going to price
discriminate them but in that setting
there is a concern that knowing the
buyers type also allows you to
personalize the goal so there's an
efficiency motive for learning the
information
so given that i
want to do the the
the example let me just give two
to remarks and then i'll i'll comment on
a bunch of open progress in this area
so why why would you think about uh
talking about this problem in uh
in the context of the data driven
decision processes or algorithmic game
theory
the first is that
one of the reasons for the existence of
this literature even though the economic
problem of like trusting the designer is
very relevant is that people were hoping
to make mechanisms simpler
so you know you make it very costly for
the principal to react to the
information because the agent goes on
and punishes him so then the principle
will become more less reactive to
information
so for instance you could think about
like non-clairvoyant mechanisms
those mechanisms don't use future
information so then
all these issues won't be present
but if you think about the
representation that we did for the
problem basically we are now
very
we're describing how the principle is
timing he's learning about the agent so
it becomes this single agent decision
process where the principal is deciding
when and how he's going to learn about
the agent's type
usually those problems from abation
setting have complicated solutions so
this literature in terms of trying to
derive simpler mechanisms did not
succeed a lot but this was one of the
sierra
of this literature
and then more in terms of
what
what can be done i think that the
representation that we get is very
useful when you're thinking about
learning algorithms so if you think
about what's happening in yashi's paper
or what solar is describing his paper
with nica so you have these agents that
are facing a learning algorithm
and all of a sudden so for instance let
me use example in yeshe's paper
the reservation price tomorrow depends
on what i beat today
and
and then i'm going to do something to
maybe beyond what i would usually do
because i mean i'm exciting just to slow
down the principles learning
and both these papers basically the
solution embeds some form of slowing
down the learning of the algorithm
to prevent the agent from overreacting
to the how the algorithm is using the
information which you can do if you have
commitment
but in a sense
you can think that once i set a learning
algorithm and if i didn't think ahead
about how this learning algorithm is
using the information the algorithm is
basically doing the best it has
with information that it receives
and
this is well well i think this is called
strategic overfitting in the in the
literature but i think that the
representation we obtain is very
relevant to think about
what learning the incentives that
learning algorithms
uh inducing these agents because the
algorithm will take the role of our
sequentially rational principle and now
what our representation says is that if
you have it it gives you
if your algorithm is patient
then it gives you a way of representing
the outcomes of the strategic
interaction between the principle
between the agents and the algorithm and
then it can give the
google amazon acquirities a
a way to compare different learning
algorithms
just by being very faithful about how
the algorithm uses the information about
the agents
so let me jump
to
last
so
thinking about how to represent
mechanism design
so mechanisms uh in the case of
immediate commitment was a long-standing
question in economics so that means that
there's a lot to do
um
and i and the most very one is that the
result that i showed you is approved for
a single agent
so there's many counter examples out
there for the results in the paper that
i mentioned from the 2000s about how
those mechanisms generalize or not for
multiple agents
our result survives these counter
examples but that doesn't mean that we
know what mechanisms are without loss
and with multiple agents there's this
question of how to aggregate multiple
the information
and there i this there's this paper that
alexoma has told me about how parenting
where
you
one agent might not want the other agent
to learn the information so
there's like impossibility results in
doing this and she told me today about
another paper in that area that sort of
has this feature of like requiring many
rounds of communication
now more practical is how do we
implement so now we have a tool like
this for single agent or if you have a
continuum of agents
uh
to think about limited commitment
how how do we implement them
do how do we implement the black box
mechanism so do we need multiple maybe
infinite brand software of communication
between the principle and the agent like
the
papal in nature paper or
would cryptographic commitments like uh
terraria and weinberg have proposed for
playable mechanisms in the case of uh
advertising will also work in this
setting
and there's like a lot of applications
to to worry about so this is a
a very uh
a very open field
and with that
i'll
say thank you because you've been very
patient with me throughout the whole
morning and i'll take questions
[Applause]
so i'm thinking back to the just the one
the two period buyer seller um
it seemed like the sort of the mechanism
of there's a price posted and the buyer
says yes or no
is that like in some sense the sort of
communications
oh so i would say that actually uh and
this and this goes back to the paper
ilan was referring to from las vegas
paper i think that the posted price has
the least information so if you if you
will observe the communication between
the with the buyer
then deposit price has the in a sense it
uses information more efficiently
like if you try to do something where
you learn a little bit about certain
types and and a little bit less about
other types like this
truncation sort of
is is an efficient way to learn for the
principal in terms of
uh the the agent's friends
when you say efficient as in it is
as in it gives the seller the
least
not the best so so basically
investigates job market paper what she
was showing is that even with limited
commitments positive prices are still
the optimum mechanism
um in a different set of mechanisms that
we were looking at but
but basically what will happen is that
you'll
your prices will decrease over time
but a
big part of the construction is sort of
showing that
there's
for any belief that you might have in
the second period actually the
truncation one
is the one that from the perspective of
the first period leaves less rents to
the agent and more value to the
principles
yes
that's why i think
this
this is very important
maybe i don't even need to check
everything that you show me in sometimes
i need it just to make sure
that it's doing the right thing but
maybe there's some easy way to just
verify even approximately that principle
is
doing
could be very complicated
is there some way to just verify that
i'm somewhat certain that everything has
been revealed and so i can go ahead
or or that's exactly what had to be
revealed
um
[Music]
i don't so i don't know for
this i actually don't know like well you
might know better than i do that whether
like even if i with a mechanism
like i someone runs an auction
and i i'm told i lost
uh
are there ways of like
checking they run the auction correctly
i don't know the way you phrased the
question also made me think this is
like for the other the extreme case that
i described where you are not committed
even to two days and i think that that's
what this paper is trying to
uh
to address how you can use cryptographic
commitments actually to do like two
rounds of
verification
uh
that the principal actually did what he
said
and that just looked like the best
responding
constraint that
believes your phone basically
the question is that i just see some
similarity between documentation
so
um i'm not trying to understand that so
our construction really relies on the
solution concept that that we use in the
sense that
we know that the principal will best
respond to his beliefs and that whatever
the agent was doing before us optional
so when we change the mechanism when we
make him tell the truth
he still has incentives to electro so it
is relying heavily on like the
sequential rationality imposed by
perfect base in equilibrium
but
i'm not sure i i'm not sure if i
understand that this is like following
the representation of
perfect basin equilibrium
it means your result is implied by
you obtain your result from the
definition of
oh yeah so the the solution concept that
we use is perfection equilibrium so as i
said before like every revelation
principle result
has
a class of mechanisms and a solution
concept and you want
this to be closed so when you go to a
simplifying class you want to be still
in the same solution concept
and we are relying quite heavily in that
we are like asking
a lot of sequentiality both from the
principal and the agent
okay so uh
[Applause]